J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: So we're
studying nucleophilic
substitution, in part at least,
as a means of seeing
how one goes about establishing
a mechanism,
proving a mechanism.
Remember that the SN2
nucleophilic substitution has
a number of components here, and
the logic is to vary them,
see how the rate changes, and
see if you can disprove some
of the mechanisms. And last time
we looked at kinetic
order and at stereochemistry,
and began looking at how the
different components influence
the rate constant.
So at the end of last time we
looked at the nucleophile, and
saw that it was unusual.
The reactivity with a carbon in
the SN2 transition state
didn't seem to parallel the
reactivity with the proton.
If you went across the first row
it was fine, but when you
went down it looked funny.
But then we saw that the solvent
had
something to do with it.
That although in water it looks
funny, it's backwards
from what you would expect.
In acetone it's sensible.
So we concluded that the solvent
makes a difference.
The solvent hydrogen-bonds in
the case of water to the
nucleophile, making it less
reactive.
The smaller, the more reactive
the nucleophile, the more it
deactivates it.
The stronger the hydrogen
bonding.
And you don't have that factor
in acetone.
But that's just one example of a
solvent effect.
There's a very general kind of
solvent effect where a polar
solvent stabilizes ions.
We saw this in the case of
water, the gas phase ions, how
much they were stabilized by
having water come around them
to the order of 100 kilocalories
per mole,
compared to the gas phase.
So whenever you generate ions,
or increase the localization
of charge, you get stronger
bonding with polar solvents.
So polar solvents accelerate
reactions that generate or
concentrate charge, because they
bind more strongly to it,
and vice versa.
If charge is being destroyed in
the reaction, than a polar
solvent will stabilize the
starting materials more than
it does the transition state,
and the
reaction will slow down.
So that's an important
consideration in choosing a
solvent for a reaction.
Now let's look at the leaving
group.
Fortunately here things make
sense.
You notice that the stronger the
acid, that is the more
weakly that the particular group
bonds to a proton, the
better it is as a leaving group.
That is it can give up its bond
to carbon, the same way
it gives up its bond to protons.
And there's a strict
parallel between how
good a nucleophile
[correction: leaving group]
is and how acidic and what
its pKa is.
So weak bases are good leaving
groups.
That is, stable anions form
easily.
Or, those that don't hold
tightly to H+, don't hold
tightly to the carbon in the
transition
state of the SN2 reaction.
So that makes perfect sense.
We looked last time at the work
of Bartlett and Knox,
this classic work of using a
bridgehead reactivity, this
bridgehead chloride, in order to
test some possibilities
about the mechanism of
nucleophilic substitution.
You can't get at the backside,
so that's out.
You can't form a double bond at
the bridgehead, so you
don't have to worry about
elimination.
The question is whether you can
have a nonplanar cation,
or whether you could attack from
the front, instead of
from the back.
And by showing that this
compound was inert to such
substitutions, they were able to
show that those inferences
were correct.
So they specifically designed
and prepared this molecule to
test these mechanistic
questions.
Incidentally, since last time I
got hold of this picture of
Lawrence Knox.
It's his graduation picture from
Bates College.
Now he had to prepare the
molecule.
How did he prepare it?
Because what we're saying is
it's very difficult to prepare
things at the bridgehead,
because you can't do
nucleophilic substitution.
That's what their experiment
showed.
So how did they do it?
Well they started with this
amine.
Actually, they started with a
product that already had the
carboxylate group in there.
And they converted that to the
amine by a reaction we'll
discuss later in the last
quarter of the semester.
But they had this compound
available.
How do they replace NH2 by Cl?
NH2 is a crummy leaving group,
and even a better leaving
group like chloride, what they
showed was that it doesn't
undergo substitutions.
So how do you put chloride in
place of the NH2?
You need some fabulous leaving
group if you want to be able
to do something at the
bridgehead.
So what they did was treat the
amine --
notice that the amine itself is
not a leaving group.
The pKa is 34.
So the higher the pKa, the worse
it is as a leaving group,
as we just saw.
If you protonated it, it would
make it a much better leaving
group because protonated NH3 the
ammonium ion has a pKa
that's 25 powers of ten better.
But still, that's not nearly
good enough to make a
bridgehead cation in order to do
substitution at the
bridgehead.
So what they did was treat the
amine with NOCl.
Now let's think about how those
would
react with one another.
What makes the NH2 reactive?
Antonia, what do you say?
STUDENT: The high HOMO?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: And the high
HOMO is--
STUDENT: The lone pair on the
nitrogen.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Right, the
lone pair on the nitrogen.
So what's it going to attack?
Antonia, keep us going.
STUDENT: The N-O pi-star.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: OK, there's a
pi-star bond of N-O. So it
could form a bond to nitrogen.
But, if you have that negative
charge on the oxygen--
that's perfectly good, and it's
almost
certainly the way it starts.
But that negative charge can
come back in, reform the bond,
and lose chloride, which is a
good leaving group.
So I'm not going to draw the
intermediate step, which is
probably correct, that you
suggested.
But just say that it displaces
the chloride.
It probably is because of the
pi-star
that does it so easily.
Although it could do it
directly.
So then we're going to have
chloride displaced and a
positive charge on this
nitrogen.
What will happen next?
How do you get rid of positive
charges on nitrogen like that?
Po-Yi?
We have an ion.
Generally there are other things
around that are better
at having positive charge than
this.
Can you think of some way you
can get rid of
that positive charge?
What did we just say about
protonated nitrogen?
Remember?
Remember its pKa is nine.
It's 25 powers of 10 better as a
leaving group--
that is to give up a proton--
than NH3 is to give up a proton
and form NH2 minus.
Much better to have NH3 as the
leaving group--
trivalent nitrogen--
rather than the anion.
So it's acidic.
It gives up a proton.
The next thing you need to do to
get toward the product--
I mean obviously this particular
reaction wasn't
figured out on paper by saying
what's the HOMO and what's the
LUMO, and so on.
They mixed it and found out what
happened.
But we can predict what's going
to happen.
But fortunately I have some
insight into what does happen,
so I know what has to happen
next.
What you have to do is have
what's called an allylic
rearrangement, where are you
shift the double bond and the
H, so the H goes from N to O.
The double bond goes between
the two Ns.
From one end to the other, of a
three atom allylic system.
How do we go about that?
Well first we can put the proton
on that
shared pair of oxygen.
That's pretty easy.
And now there's a resonance
structure of that involving
the unshared pair on nitrogen
again.
So we can go in, and the pi
electrons can go on to oxygen
in the resonance structure we're
talking about.
So now we've done the allylic
rearrangement, except it's
still got a positive charge on
the nitrogen.
Po-Yi, what do you do now?
To get rid of the positive
charge on the nitrogen?
STUDENT: The proton leaves?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Right.
You lose the proton again.
Now you do the same thing again.
Watch this.
So you protonate the water.
And now use the unshared pair of
the nitrogen.
And we're going to draw two
arrows.
So you form a triple bond
between the two nitrogens, and
water is the good leaving group.
So we have that.
And now that truly is a fabulous
leaving group.
What is the leaving group?
What's going to leave?
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Nitrogen.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: N2.
I looked.
I couldn't find a pKa for
protonated N2.
It just has no affinity for a
proton on at all.
I couldn't find it.
But it's certainly a very, very
strong acid.
Protonated nitrogen gas.
So it's a very good leaving
group.
And you get N2, and it as a
leaving group can generate
even a bridgehead cation, the
thing that you
can't do with chloride.
Even with the help of silver ion
as
Bartlett and Knox found.
So once you have that, remember
we already got the
chloride from the first
reaction.
So you just put that in, and
that's how they made it.
So there are leaving groups even
better than these.
N2 is a fabulous leaving group,
and can even make the
bridgehead cation.
Now this idea of protonating or
charging things in order that
they leave as neutral molecules
like N2, is also
present in molecules in the list
we already have here.
Like ROH.
That's a very bad leaving group,
OH minus.
However, if you protonate it,
then you have water as the
leaving group and that's good.
You've changed the pKa by 17.5
powers of 10.
units.
That is the equilibrium constant
by that
many powers of 10.
So that becomes very good.
And in fact there's another good
way of doing it.
So that's acid catalysis to help
lose OH, that is you lose
it as water not as OH minus.
And another way is to convert it
into a sulfonate ester,
which is a good leaving group.
Did you ever see that before?
To have that complicated thing
leave instead of OH minus?
Because of the new dispensation
that the exam is
going to be on Friday rather
than Wednesday, you have a
whole week to learn that.
So that was what Kenyon and
Phillips did, remember, in
order to study the inversion.
So there are leaving group
tricks, and there's lore about
that, of what you could do to
help make OH a leaving group.
You can protonate it and have
the leaving group be H2O.
So that could be the leaving
group, OH2+, and then it
leaves as H2O.
So we can look at an example of
that.
So here's bromide going to
displace hydroxide.
So we can imagine it coming on,
and hydroxide going off.
But there's a problem with this.
The pKa of water is 16, roughly.
And the pKa of HBr is -5.
So one way to say it is that
bromide is a much better anion
than hydroxide is.
When one of them is going to be
protonated.
What does that mean about this
reaction?
That you'd rather have bromide
than have hydroxide.
Luke, what does that say about
this reaction?
Going to make a lot of money
doing that reaction?
STUDENT: Probably not.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Why not?
STUDENT: Well, that probably
wouldn't happen.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: I can't hear
very well.
STUDENT: That probably wouldn't
happen.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: What would
happen?
STUDENT: The--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: You'd go the
other direction.
So it would go that way.
And so you'd start with an
expensive starting material
and make cheap product if you
want to use that reaction.
But if you put HBr in there.
You protonate it, because HBr
has a pKa of 5
[correction: -5].
But water or alcohol, has a pKa
of -1.7.
So there's a difference between
that of over three.
So it's more than a thousand
times better to protonate the
oxygen, than it is to protonate
Br-.
So this reaction will certainly
go
in the right direction.
And now you have a great leaving
group.
So bromide is a good nucleophile
and
will displace water.
So if you just tried using
sodium bromide as the source
of bromide, it wouldn't work.
But if you use hydrobromic acid,
then you zip up the
starting material and now it's
downhill to the product.
And you can cleave ethers.
You know ether is a common
solvent.
I suspect you've used ether in
lab.
Because it doesn't react well
with--
you can have lots of
nucleophiles in there, but you
don't displace OR minus.
That's not a good leaving group.
It's like OH minus.
But if you use HBr like this
example here, excess 47% HBr,
treated for eight hours.
It protonates.
And now you have a good leaving
group.
So you have a good nucleophile,
and a good
leaving group.
The bromide can attack the
carbon, and the alcohol is the
leaving group.
And then we already saw that the
alcohol reacts with HBr to
give bromide.
So you convert the ether
completely to the bromide if
you add HBr.
So HBr can cleave ethers.
So that's one trick to make OH-
into a leaving group.
To make OH into OH2+.
Another one is the one we
already alluded to and talked
about last time.
Which is to convert the alcohol
into what's called a
sulfonate ester.
A tosylate.
The reason it's called tosylate,
is that acid is
called toluenesulfonic acid.
So it's abbreviated tosic acid.
So tosylate is the leaving
group.
The pKa of that acid is -3.
So it's not surprising it's a
good leaving group.
It worked well for Kenyon and
Phillips in 1923.
That's a very common way to make
alcohols
into leaving groups.
Another way is talked about in
the Jones
text, which is OSOCl.
So the way to get that is to
start, as they say here,
with thionyl chloride,
SOCl2, which reacts with the
alcohol, to give an alkyl
chloride plus SO2 and HCl.
And there's an example shown
here of a particular acid
being converted with thionyl
chloride, chloroform, 100
degrees, two hours, into an 80%
yield, they say of this,
plus SO2 and HCl.
80% is not such a great yield
for this reaction.
This is one of the reactions
I've done a lot, and it really
gets very, very good yields
typically.
One of the reasons it's so handy
is that the
byproducts are gases.
So you don't have to do any
separation, they just go away.
You can appreciate from lab how
handy it would be if you
didn't have to do any
purification of the product at
the end, everything just went up
the hood.
And furthermore, there seems to
be a little bit of a
problem here.
Because they said they did this
in chloroform at
100 degrees.
It could be that the bath was at
100 degrees, but if so the
solution wasn't at 100 degrees.
Does anybody have an idea why
that might be?
Because the boiling point of
chloroform is 61, and the
boiling point of thionyl
chloride is 75, so it'd be
very difficult to get a solution
like that heated to
100 degrees.
So the reason I point this out
on this page from the book, is
that Professor Jones is a great
friend of mine, and a
very good physical organic
chemist. And he's taken the
care in his book, as in most
good books, to actually put in
real examples, not just
theoretical examples made up
out of your head.
There was a very famous
professor in the in the first
half of the twentieth century at
MIT whose occupation in the
summer was to write textbooks.
But he did it by going up to his
cabin in Maine, and
writing the textbooks there,
where he had
no access to a library.
So everything he wrote, he made
up out
of his head in there.
Much better to have an example
like this where they give
exactly what the yield is, 80%,
and what
the conditions were.
But even in this case, I
doubt that that
really was the condition.
Although that might have been
what the heating mantle was,
at a 100 degrees.
But the solution couldn't
possibly
have been at 100 degrees.
Even though when you mix things
the boiling point is
elevated, but it wouldn't be
that much
elevated I don't think.
But the reason I mention that is
not just to point out that
you have to take things with a
grain of salt and look as much
as you can at original
literature, if you really want
to repeat some process, but to
point out that thionyl
chloride is not a very high
boiling liquid.
So in fact all you do is take
the alcohol--
You don't need chloroform, at
least I never used a solvent.
This is a liquid.
This'll dissolve this.
And the product chloride is a
liquid even with bigger
molecules where the alcohol
might be a solid.
So you just heat it up for a
while, reflux it, and then
distill out.
And this SOCl2 distills out, the
SO2 and HCl distills out,
and all you're left with is the
alkyl chloride.
It's a beautiful reaction.
OK and here's an example that
shows the mechanism of this.
The crucial part is this.
The alcohol displaces at sulfur.
So the chloride goes away, and
you get R-O, and this is the
new bond, SOCl.
Oh pardon, me.
I said the wrong thing at first.
You displace one of
these chlorides with the O. So
you get ROSOCl.
But now the neat reaction is
that you generated chloride in
that process, when you
eliminated a chloride here.
That chloride can do an SN2
displacement on the R. These
electrons go in here, but at the
same time these electrons
go on to the chloride.
So you directly make SO2 and Cl.
So it's an unusual kind of
leaving group, because it
breaks apart as it leaves.
Now another way to make the OH
into a leaving group, is to
have phosphorus on there with
electron
withdrawing groups on it.
Because as it turns out, the
double bond between phosphorus
and oxygen is quite a strong
one.
Remember that phosphorus has d
orbitals that are vacant.
So they can stabilize the
electrons on the adjacent
oxygen when you make a negative
charge there.
And if X is something that's
electronegative this is a very
good leaving group.
So here's an example of an
alcohol treated with PBr3 and
it gives a 58% yield they said
here with specific conditions,
and phosphoric acid is a
byproduct.
And here's another example,
using PCl5.
It says 100%.
Beware of things that say the
yield is 100%, that's a sign
that the person probably wasn't
very careful.
Have you ever gotten 100% yield
in lab?
These people maybe have more
experience than you, but
they're not that much better.
Very rarely do you truly get
100% yield.
Now how does this work?
Well, first you do a
substitution at phosphorus.
So the O of the OH, attacks
phosphorus
and displaces chloride.
Probably that's A/D, association
and dissociation.
Probably you first form a bond
to phosphorus, remember it has
vacant d orbitals, and then the
chloride leaves.
So you have this with these
electronegative groups on it,
and now that can be a good
leaving group.
So you've converted OH into this
good leaving group.
Why is that particular one of
interest in context of what
we've been talking about lately?
What's interesting about that
particular R group to do a
substitution at that carbon?
Linda?
STUDENT: You can't attack the
back.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: I can't hear
very well.
STUDENT: You can't do a backside
attack.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Ahah!
You can't do a backside attack.
This is like the Bartlett-Knox
thing.
It's set up so you can't get a
nucleophile to the backside.
The alternative, remember, was
to have it
leave, and leave a cation.
Just leave without the help from
being pushed backside.
But, what we learn from this,
the fact that we got 100%
yield, is that we can do that.
So these rings are bigger.
Remember the one that Bartlett
and Knox made.
The bridges were two carbons,
two carbons, and one carbon.
Here the rings are much bigger,
so it's easier to
distort the angles in order to
flatten the rings.
So we can do substitution
involving bridgehead cations,
just not when the rings are very
small.
But what you learn here is that
this leaving group is
good enough to do that, even
though it's a bridgehead.
Another trick is this one called
the Appel Reaction.
I took this figure from
Wikipedia.
The reagents that you add to the
alcohol, are
triphenylphosphine and carbon
tetrachloride, an unusual
reagent.
You more often would think of
that as a
solvent then as a reagent.
But as you see, what happens is
the unshared pair on
phosphorus does a substitution
on carbon tetrachloride.
But the phosphorus attacks
chloride, not carbon.
So it attacks the chloride and
CCl3 minus
is the leaving group.
Because the three chlorines are
sufficiently electron
attractive, that the anion is
not a bad anion.
The pKa of chloroform is 24, so
it's pretty easy to
generate that anion and lose a
proton.
Now notice at this stage when
you add the alcohol, its pKa
is about 17, so the
trichloromethyl anion,
although it's unusually stable
for a carbon anion, is much
more avid to get a proton, than
the O of the alcohol is.
So this base that you've made in
the first reaction, the
leaving group takes the proton
off the alcohol and
now you have OR-.
But now you have the possibility
for chloride to
attack this carbon where you've
made
this new bond here.
That's probably an association
followed by dissociation.
But notice the substitution is
at phosphorus, because the O
attacked the phosphorus and
chloride came off.
So here's the chloride.
It does a nucleophilic
substitution now at carbon,
and Ph3PO, triphenylphosphine
oxide, is the leaving group.
And that's a super leaving
group.
This is a very strong bond, the
P-O double bond there.
So this converted what would
have been an OH leaving group
into this triphenylphosphine
cation, which leaves to make
triphenylphosphine oxide.
So again you've made a very good
leaving
group out of an oxygen.
So what this shows is that
they're lots of
ways to skin a cat.
OH minus is a terrible leaving
group, but we have lots of
different ways of going at it.
You can protonate it.
You can use SOCl2.
You can use the phosphorus
chlorides or bromides.
Phosphorus halides.
And you can do this funny trick
in the Appel Reaction
using triphenylphosphine and
carbon tetrachloride.
Here's an example from the Jones
book,
where the OH is made into a
leaving group by
triphenylphosphine and carbon
tetrachloride.
It says it was done over a day
at room temperature, and
here's the chloride.
Notice it inverted. The presence
of deuteriums here
allows you to know whether the
configuration
is retained or inverted.
And as you expect with an SN2
reaction, it's inverted.
So we've looked a lot at this
mechanism.
Let's see how you can use
knowledge of the mechanism to
do something useful.
In this particular case it was
to maximize synthetic speed in
order to make PET scanning
possible.
Do people know what PET scanning
is?
PET, what the P stands for?
STUDENT: Positron.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: The P is
positron.
And what is a positron?
It's something you don't
encounter very often.
You can't buy a bottle of it.
STUDENT: Antimatter.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Pardon me?
STUDENT: It's antimatter.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: It's
antimatter.
It's a positive electron.
It's an electronic that has a
positive charge instead of a
negative charge.
So that's a positron.
Now where do you get positrons?
STUDENT: Magic...
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: You get them
by nuclear decay.
Unstable isotopes decay to give
a number of particles,
especially in the case of F-18.
F-18 can have one of its protons
in the
nucleus become a neutron.
That is it's the same particle,
but it loses a
positive charge.
So a proton becomes a neutron.
So instead of fluoride, it's now
oxygen.
So you've made a new element.
And it's lost a positive charge.
So if it was F-, it's oxygen
double minus.
But it's the same mass, 18,
because all you lost was this
positive electron.
Now when you have a positive
electron, it goes away
instantly because the antimatter
meets it's
corresponding matter, an
electron right where it lives.
It's made right there, but
they're a zillion electrons
around, even on the same atom
there are electrons.
So when the electron and a
positron meet one another,
they annihilate.
They go away, and what comes out
is two photons, gamma
particles, which as you saw,
flew off antiparallel to one
another along the same line.
So if you have a detector you
see a flash here and a
detection over there as well.
Now you can do that again and
again.
You can get, bingo, those two
happen at the same time.
Because they came from the same
decay.
Or those two.
So if you surround the thing
with the detector that
can tell when things hit it,
when two things hit it at the
same time, they came from the
same nuclear decay.
Now do you see what you could do
with respect to imaging?
How can you tell where the
sample that
had F-18 was?
All you know is where these
things hit your detector.
You see what you do to figure
out where they came from?
Yigit?
STUDENT: Trace the lines--
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Aha, yes.
You trace lines.
So if you connect those, where
they intersect is where the
fluorine-18 was.
Each line comes from one
fluorine-18, but the sample
had a number of fluorine-18's in
it.
So you find out where the sample
was.
If you want to use this imaging
to find tumors, you
have to find some way to get
fluorine-18 to
where the tumor is.
And then if you surround the
patient with this detector and
measure these simultaneous
flashes, or detection events,
then you know where that
substance was.
So if you can make that
substance be in the tumor,
then you're home free.
You can read about it, as I did,
in Wikipedia.
But you have to do this really
quickly after you've prepared
the element.
So you prepare the element,
F-18, but its half-life is
only 110 minutes.
So you don't have much time to
make it into something that
will go where the tumor is.
So speed is of the essence in
doing whatever kind of
synthesis you're going to get.
Now where do you get F-18?
You get it from O-18, the same
as the product by adding a
proton and losing a neutron.
So you don't change the mass,
but you put a positive charge
into the nucleus so you get
fluorine instead of oxygen.
OK fine if you have O-18--you
buy O-18, but where are you
going to get a proton that's
going really fast?
Seven million electron volts.
You have to get it from an
accelerator.
From a cyclotron.
Now you can also do it in place
of fluorine you could
have carbon, or nitrogen, or
oxygen, but they have even
shorter half-lives.
So you have to work even quicker
in order to have any
there at the time to get it
where you
want it to be detected.
Now if you go on to the
petcenter.yale.edu, you see
that they do this positron
emission tomography.
And you see what they have is a
cyclotron that generates
these high-energy protons, that
can convert one element
into one of these radioactive
elements that
will generate positrons.
And you see they have a water
target so that
you can produce fluoride.
They also have targets to
produce those other elements I
talked about.
And they say they also have two
fluorine-18 synthesis modules--
one for nucleophilic
substitution, and one for
electrophilic substitution.
So they have the facility for
making this stuff and then
doing reactions quickly with it,
but the question is what
are you going to synthesize so
that it will go to a tumor, so
you can find where the tumor is?
And you have to do it really
quickly.
Well glucose is the basis of
metabolism, and tumors are
growing rapidly, so they really
snarf up glucose.
So if you had F-18 in glucose,
that might do the trick.
If you could make
2-fluoroglucose, with an F-18
in it, maybe that would be
sucked up by the tumors the
same way that glucose is.
So we need to make that molecule
as quickly as
possible from glucose.
Well, let's just do a
nucleophilic substitution.
Fluoride in, hydroxide out.
Does that sound good?
Or might there be problems with
that in
doing the SN2 reaction?
Can you think of a problem doing
this reaction?
Fluoride comes in, displaces OH
to give the compound on the
right which has the same shape
as glucose.
Lauren, what's the funny problem
you see?
STUDENT: OH isn't a good leaving
group.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: The hydroxide
is a
crummy leaving group.
Whoops, and it was supposed to
come up there, but it didn't.
I had anticipated you.
I think I did.
Let's see what the next one is.
Yes.
But it could be that the wrong
carbon gets attacked.
There are lots of OH's here.
Even if it could be attacked,
the others
could be just as good.
And if you did SN2 displacement
at the oxygen,
even if you attack that one, it
would give the wrong
fluorine-18 arrangement.
There's Lauren's.
It's a terrible leaving group.
That's not all that's wrong with
this.
A fluoride is a horrid
nucleophile as we saw.
It's tied up by
hydrogen-bonding.
So you have to break the
hydrogen bonds.
And it's very small and highly
charged, so it has very strong
hydrogen bonds.
And furthermore, it's tied up by
the potassium cation which
makes it less reactive.
So you've got lots and lots of
problems, so that doesn't look
like it's going to do the trick.
Now can we address these
problems on the basis of what
we've been talking about?
Can we figure out some way of
doing it so we can do this
transformation really rapidly
after the cyclotron generates
this stuff, that half of it's
going away every couple hours.
How about the SN2 inversion
gives the wrong configuration?
What could we do to get the
right configuration if we did
an inversion?
Use a different starting
material.
And it turns out that mannose,
which has this OH axial
pointing up is readily
available.
It's a different sugar.
And if you did substitution on
that, you'd get the equatorial
thing that you wanted.
So that's no problem.
Now we have the problem that the
wrong CO could be attacked.
There are one, two, three, four,
five
different C-OH's in here.
So what you have to do is make
one of them
different from the others.
The one you want to attack has
to be
different from the others.
And the way you do it has been
known a long
time in sugar chemistry.
Which is, you can protect some
of the groups
and not another one.
So what's done here is to put
acetyl groups on all the other
four, but not on this particular
OH.
How that's done we won't go into
now.
That's a topic in sugar
chemistry.
But you know how to do it.
But there's a problem here still
that OH minus is a horrid
leaving group.
It's now different from the
others, but it's a horrid
leaving group and acetate is a
better leaving group.
It's a more acidic compound--
acetic acid--
than water.
Better anion.
So what are we going to do now?
Lauren, this was your problem.
That the OH minus, was a bad
leaving group.
What can we do?
STUDENT: Try to protonate it.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: We could
protonate it, but you could
protonate the acetates too and
make them better leaving
groups, so that won't do the
trick.
What they did, was convert it
into a sulfonic acid.
The one that Kenyon and Phillips
did had a phenyl
group here, or toluene
actually--
a benzene with a methyl on the
edge of it.
This is CF3.
Why might CF3 three be better
than just a regular old
hydrocarbon like toluene?
It's got the fluorines in it
that are electron withdrawing.
So it makes the anion that
you're
going to want to leave--
this OSO2CF3 is a much stronger
acid, a much more
stable anion, and a better
leaving group.
The pKa of the corresponding
acid here is -14.
It's called a super acid.
Remember that the strongest that
we've talked about so
far, had a pKa of -11.
This is a 1,000 times stronger
than HI.
So we put on a really super
leaving group.
It's trifluormethansulfonate,
and called triflate.
So now we have a compound that's
as good as we can make
it for being attacked at this
center, not the others.
For having a great leaving
group, and for having the
proper stereochemistry so that
we'll get the fluoride where
we want it.
And now we have to do the
reaction with fluoride.
Notice that all this can be done
ahead of time.
We can have the bottom right
molecule, take however much
time we want to make it.
Now we have it in a bottle.
We go to the cyclotron at the
medical school, get
fluoride-18, and try to do our
substitution.
Now we have to introduce the
fluoride-18.
So we have to go from this
protected triflate to this
compound as soon as we can,
because the fluorides
getting off these positrons all
the time.
So let's react it with potassium
fluoride, with
fluoride-18.
What's the problem?
The fluoride is tied up by
hydrogen bonding.
It's not a good nucleophile.
How could we get around that
problem with the hydrogen
bonding deactivating fluoride?
Any ideas on that one?
How can you do that?
Lauren?
STUDENT: Could changing the
solvent help?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Change the
solvent to something that
can't make hydrogen bonds.
So they use acetonitrile, methyl
cyanide, which doesn't
have any hydrogen bonding
protons in it.
It has CH protons, but those
aren't involved in hydrogen
bonding, so that's no problem.
But we still have this last
problem.
The potassium cation is going to
be tightly associated with
the fluroide, and we're going to
have to break it away to
make the fluoride more reactive.
How can we get rid of the
potassium cation?
Remember the problem is that a
single potassium atom is
rather small.
If it were big then it wouldn't
attract by Coulomb's
Law, the fluoride so tightly.
Then you wouldn't have to worry
about it.
How could we make potassium big?
Arvind, did you have an idea?
STUDENT: Don't atoms get bigger
if you add an electron?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Well, if you
add an electron to the
potassium cation, it's not a
cation anymore.
It's not the thing that's
associated.
It has to still be a cation, but
you
want to make it bigger.
How do you make a potassium
cation big?
Nate?
STUDENT: Move the electrons to
higher energy orbitals.
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: That's an
interesting idea, but I don't
think it's practical, because
you couldn't have enough light
to make a significant number of
them bigger all at the same
time, without just blowing
everything apart.
Matt?
STUDENT: Could you separate it
using a crown ether?
PROFESSOR MCBRIDE: Aha!
Crown ether.
Or even better, a cryptate.
So you make it big that way.
And now the fluoride is a good
nucleophile.
There's no hydrogen bonding.
The cation is really big.
And now you can do that.
So that's how they do it.
So it's all using these ideas to
figure out how to tune the
SN2 reaction to make it as
efficient as possible.
And of course there's one more
step.
You have to then take off these
acetate groups.
But you can do that just by
treating it
with water and acid.
Here's an example of a PET scan
image that's measured one
hour after administering.
So you not only have to make the
stuff, you have to give it
to the patient, and the patient
has to process it
enough that compound gets to
where the tumor is.
It just goes to where glucose is
being consumed.
The 2-fluoroglucose.
One place that a lot of glucose
is being
consumed is up there.
Where's that?
Is it happening for you?
If I had given you
2-fluoroglucose, and was
looking at your positrons, would
I see
them coming from here?
That's where a lot of
metabolism--
but unfortunately also there.
And if we slice through there,
and tip it up you can see that
that's the tumor that was
located this way.
So the metabolism is in the
brain, but also in the
cancerous lymphnode.
Understanding how nucleophilic
substitution works, and how to
control it was crucial in
designing this technique.
Now one last topic, which
I'll just introduce
here and then we'll
complete next time.
We've talked about
stereochemistry, rate law, and
rate constant.
But can you do actual structural
work?
Remember how we talked about the
mechanism of a nucleophile
attacking a carbonyl group?
And you could do it by X-ray?
You could get a bunch of
different compounds and add
nitrogens in different positions
relative to the
carbonyl, and you could put them
together in sort of a
movie in the Burgi-Dunitz
material that we did last
semester and see the stage of
the reaction.
Might you be able to do that for
nucleophilic substitution?
Might you be able to use X-ray,
and if not X-ray at
least use quantum mechanics, to
see what the structure of
this intermediate is.
Because so far we've mostly been
beating up on the
dissociation/association
mechanisms. Most of the things
we've disproven are things that
involve that mechanism
with the trivalent carbon
intermediate.
Although it can happen, and
we're going to
talk about it next--
go through the intermediate
cation.
So there are some cases where it
in fact applies.
But the tougher problem is to
distinguish between concerted
and association/dissociation
with a very weakly stabilized
pentavalent intermediate.
There's stuff on the course
website about that.
But the question is, might there
be a pentavalent
intermediate instead of the
concerted transition state?
So here's the transition state,
which
is an energy maximum.
Here's the pentavalent
intermediate.
So there would be nothing to see
at the
transition state here.
It wouldn't last any time.
It's just passing through.
But if there were a little
dimple up at the top, there
could be some stability.
That is, that is a stable
pentavalent carbon.
But does it exist?
You can see that it would merge
smoothly into one if it
just had a teeny tiny dimple, or
a little bit bigger dimple.
If it were big enough, you might
be able to prepare it
under some circumstances where
you could actually
see it, say an X-ray.
But if it's too small, you're
never going to see it.
You might be able to try to
calculate
it by quantum mechanics.
So the question is, is there an
example of
a pentavalent carbon?
So by quantum mechanics, they
said that for water,
displacing H2O, that cation,
that symmetrical compound
there is actually a transition
state, not an intermediate.
It goes downhill if you lengthen
one bond
and shorten the other.
The same is true in the anion.
These are calculations of
isolated
materials, so gas phase.
If you have OH minus come in and
displace OH minus, that
one quantum mechanics also says
is transition state.
But neither reaction is
practical in the laboratory.
So the question is, what does
experiment say?
Can you do X-ray studies and
actually see whether there
might be a stable pentavalent--
maybe very transiently stable,
very weakly
stabilized, but might that
pentavalent compound be stable?
So that's what we'll talk about
with the X-ray
material next time.